was mich wirklich stört ist dass die
politik und ich sage jetzt mal die
politik sich so sehr in unser
privatleben hinein möchte das geht
einfach nicht mehr die energie sparen
glaube ich ist jeden menschen in
deutschland bewusst dass notwendig und
ich kenne nur menschen die sich gedanken
machen wo sie mit der energie
sorgfältiger umgehen bewusster so wird
erst mal ausdrücken aber ich möchte mir
nicht von herrn habe vorschreiben lassen
wie lange ich dusche und wie waren mein
duschwasser zu sein hat ich möchte mir
von herrn kretschmann nicht sagen lassen
dass ich doch besser statt duschen einen
waschlappen benutzer so ist eine total
unhygienische geschichte denn wenn ich
einen waschlappen nicht mache dann werde
ich den wohl dann in die kosmische geben
müssen und am nächsten tag wieder einen
neuen benutzen also was ist das für eine
energieverschwendung ich will mir auch
nicht sagen lassen dass das dass ich
jetzt mein mann meine wohnung auf eine
bestimmte temperatur hinunter dem man
muss ja ich erwarte dass demnächst die
wärme polizei auftaucht und nach schaut
man mir vor riegel haben sie jetzt 19
grad oder ist bei in etwa sogar
vielleicht 20 oder oben gott ist wenn 21
grad wenn ich dann muss ich dann strafe
zahlen muss ich den kaminkehrer
hineinlassen wer darf denn eigentlich
das überprüfen und ich habe sie
vielleicht sogar ins gefängnis wenn man
es ganz womöglich war hat mich wäre wenn
ich sage ich mache jetzt 22 grad wobei
ich wirklich betone energie sparen und
sinnvoll umgehen mit energie ist
wirklich notwendig ja
aber ich habe heute mit meine frisur mit
friseuren gesprochen und habe erzählt
dass friseure künftig nur noch mit
kaltem wasser in die haare waschen
dürfen ja da hat sie also schnell auf
gelacht und gesagt dann macht sie
einladen so ich finde es beängstigend
dass die das dass das unsere städte
abgedunkelt werden ja das denke ich kann
ich dann macht's noch durch die straßen
gehen also licht ist doch auch notwendig
um mich zu schützen und ich finde auch
persönlich es gibt
denkmäler wahrzeichen in einer stadt wo
sondern ich jedes beleuchtet werden aber
diese wahrzeichen sind ein symbol für
unsere für unser zusammenleben ein
symbol auch für unsere kultur und ich
finde das wichtig dass ich die auch
nachts sehe man kann in so vielen ecken
und enden sparen aber es dann geht es
zum beispiel darum habe ich heute
gelesen wie verschiedene berufe die
kälte stufen verschiedene berufe also
wenn ich sitze dann darf ich bei 19 grad
sitzen wenn ich mich dabei bewege dann
wird es auf 1817 grad und es geht wenn
die mich besonders bewegend nur noch bei
14 grad wer stellt eigentlich fest wie
sehr ich mich beim arbeiten bisher als
sie schon sind titel jetzt haben wir auf
betriebstemperatur einer das habe ich
selbst verständnis für sie und dass sie
sich nicht in ihre persönliche hygiene
reinreden wollen danke da habe ich sehr
viel verständnis dafür aber wissen sie
ich glaube wichtig ist dass wir jetzt
hier als deutschland durch den winter
kommen danke sagen wir leisten
solidarität mit der ukraine ich bin der
meinung wir brauchen jetzt von unserer
regierung macht wenn die sommerpause
vorbei ist wirklich konzepte die tauben
und die vor allem der bevölkerung keine
angst machen also ich habe das gefühl
dass einige kollegen morgens auf den
twitter knopf aufwachen und den ersten
gedanken der ebenso morgens in den kopf
kommt dabei wurde eine liste mit degen
aber jetzt reden wir aber über energie
gerade
das macht leuten angst ich krieg mich
leute die in einem wahlkreis zu mir
kommen und sagen aber ich habe in meinem
wahlkreis verdient 50 prozent der leute
1500 euro netto ja das heißt also
wirklich keine bayerischen probleme
rechte geht die angst die angst ich
glaube die angst müsste nicht sein wenn
wir einfach noch ein bisschen ruhe
bewahren würden wenn wir vernünftig was
ausarbeiten würden ideen die ausgegoren
durchgerechnet sind dann sagen würden
das könnte unser weg aber härter sein
ist doch nicht nur die komponenten
republik kann man doch schon jahre
vorher nicht so genannten republik was
waren die gründe kidaid über gutmenschen
nutzen was ist eigentlich die männliche
vor mit gender zeiten von
komponenten an ticks oder oder was man
sich es ist doch vorher schon wir
bleiben einmal eine einheit agogisch
gesagt worden nein ich bin jetzt bei
dieser erziehungs und google
es ist doch vorher schon gesagt worden
farblos kenneth suv farblos keinen
diesel farblos fliegt bloß nicht in den
urlaub es ist nicht mehr als ein mal in
der woche fleisch und weiß der teufel
was allem aber erklärt jan er aber
würden sie dann sagen dass wir jetzt
über den geldbeutel erzogen werden
aber auch na also den steuerten oder
augen hat in welcher preiskategorie
tischen einfach werde ich mir einfach
sehen dass sollten die jetzt aus einem
billigtarif kommen zu den stadtwerken
zurück wollen gar nicht mehr angenommen
werden in meiner region 30 cent pro
kilowattstunde gas bezahlen ist eine 98
prozentige gasversorgung habe und diese
wette eben einfach nicht mehr
funktionierte weiter managergehälter und
schöngeister um dem winter machen darum
brauchen wir jetzt ein durchgängiges
konzept wie wir leute mit niedrigen
einkommen entlasten nein nein
sagen es geht mir nicht nur um meine
sorge um die jobs pädagogische genannten
republik dass das war nicht fallen
republik das war eine sehr aus dass
merck einer denunzianten republik wir
haben denunziation einrichtungen von
kommunen bekommen wo menschen in
irgendeiner stadt in nordrhein westfalen
die süddeutsche zeitung übrigens hat ist
ein redakteur gemacht ja anonym melden
konnten wenn einer in der zeit als man
höchstens zwei oder vier angehörige in
der ersten carola phase entscheidung
gelassen
guggenheim republik den ozean kraus wir
müssen aber ich habe wohl eine frage sag
ich gebe aber ich gebe bei meinem
nachbarrecht ja nach corona ist jetzt
die energie also den die neue prüfstelle
und als jungs mit neuer
erziehungsmethode denn wissen sie ich
finde energie sparen wichtig nicht
sinnvoll sondern wichtig und ich glaube
dass die meisten menschen sich auch
dessen bewusst sein denn was ich nicht
verbraucher muss ich nicht bezahlen also
die menschen drehen freiwillig die
heizung runter sie überlegen sich ob sie
eine lange reise machen entschuldigen
die meisten menschen hat runter weil sie
sich nicht leisten können diese rechnung
zu mitarbeiter
ihre energiepolitik dazu muss ich aber
sagen dass es glücklicherweise in
deutschland viele viele und hilfen gibt
ja ich habe mir angeschaut was die stadt
münchen zum beispiel macht um menschen
mit niedrigerem einkommen über diese
über diesen schwierigen winter hinweg zu
helfen da gibt es also zum beispiel wenn
wenn ich die heizung nicht bezahlen kann
und
es wird mir droht das stellen wir ab den
strom und die heizung gibt es eine
stelle wo ich mich melden kann es wird
niemanden die heizung oder der strom in
münchen abgestellt da bin ich mir ganz
sicher es ist umständlich und schwierig
und ich weiß das ist für die mehrheit
der deutschen sehr schwierig sein wird
das alles zu bezahlen wir fragen aber
einer außerdem habe ich mich sowieso nur
warum zum beispiel dieser
heizkostenzuschuss warum der allen
bezahlt wird ich hätte diesen
heizkostenzuschuss gedeckelt bis zu
einem bestimmten einkommen dann hätten
sie nämlich auch mehr bekommen können
denn zwar 300 euro wenn ich das mal dann
noch wenn ich noch die steuern abgezogen
bekommen ja das ist ja ein tropfen auf
den heißen stein da geht es ja vor allem
um die heizkosten der vergangenheit und
dieser weg wurde gewählt weil er einfach
einfach zu administrieren ist weil sie
jetzt mit dem gehalt einfach alle
menschen erreichen der arbeitgeber zahlt
es mit dem gehalt auszahlt weniger lohn
nebenkosten start und so haben wir es
einfach gelöst quasi ohne simon was
beantragen muss darum ging es wir fragen
jetzt mal hätte er auch betroffen ist
und wenn sie das jetzt zu sein herr als
sagt das ist zu viel panikmache auf
twitter so schlimm würzen auch wenn sie
frau regiert sind wie sehen sie denn die
lager die frage ist ja wer macht denn
die panik die panik kommt ja wirklich
überwiegend auch von herrn h weg der
sagt es wird ganz bremsweg werden oder
von herrn müller der sagt wir werden mit
100 prozent auch nicht überall
winterkompletträder haben translate
selbstverständlich also für meine
branche ist extrem bremslicht weil wir
brauchen dringend dünner und dünner also
mineralischer dünger wird mit glas
produziert den gibt es faktisch gar
nicht aktuell egal was sie bezahlen
wollen die läger sind leer und ich
erwarte jetzt auch als normaler bürger
lösungen wir waren alle drei herren hier
waren beim militär so wir müssen in der
lage leben wann kommt die lösung weil
wir haben jetzt eine neue lage ich
möchte jetzt nicht hören und ich möchte
nicht sehen dass herr habig unter scholz
jetzt nach kanada fliegen allen ernstes
dort windenergieanlagen in neufundland
geplant werden die es noch gar nicht
gibt da gibt's doch gar keine jene gegen
jung keine pläne kein garnichts
wunderschöne landschaft ich war übrigens
mal da müssen wir hin fahren welche
lösung haben sie denn die lösung hat
legen hier bei uns in niedersachsen
unter der erde sie haben 23 milliarden
kubikmeter gas an die wir ohne flecken
herankommen 2009 10 hat die
bundesregierung unter frau merkel noch
eine studie in auftrag gegeben können
wir tatsächlich
nachhaltig so nachhaltig wie möglich
schrecken antwort ja warum machen wir
das nicht müssen sich auf dauer machen
aber wenigstens zwei drei jahre bis wir
in der lage sind tat sich uns autark zu
versorgen das in kanada wird mindestens
sechs jahre dauern falls überhaupt
möglich ist und wir haben lassen sie
erst einmal das
wäre jetzt geht's um ganz raten aber
wenig bei zum energiebedarf aber
natürlich können wir die arbeit kommt
jeder und jede kultur anbieter hat
stunde höre ich ja aber warum ich frage
mich auch als ehrlich also warum das
immer schwieriger leute anderen strecken
empfehlen oder gasförderung wenn sie
selber nicht vor der haustür haben sie
wissen ja selber energieversorgung
energieproduktion ist nie beliebt egal
ob sich atomkraftwerk vor der haustür
haben oder eine windmühle es gibt immer
gegenwind und keiner will's nicht
subventioniert vom staat und da wurden
die regeln aufgeweicht und windenergie
zum beispiel da scheint mir oft dass die
regierung gar kein problem damit hat
einem bürger in windrad vor die tür zu
setzen
das genauso auch beim fasching
querstellen mittags windräder bei uns ab
weil der strom nicht wegkommt und jetzt
wollen wir tatsächlich das in kanada in
neufundland windenergieanlagen aufgebaut
werden die haben wie hier vor ort warum
setzen wir das nicht ein warum suchen
wir immer auf der anderen welt und sie
sagen gerade genau das richtige was wie
eine landschaft erleben die haben wir
haben also windräder die nicht an das
netz angeschlossen hätten die
übertragungsnetze die die höchster
netzkapazität ja ist gerade nach
süddeutschland zu gering weil sich halt
seit jahren jahrzehnten dagegen gewehrt
dass die übertragungsnetze gebrauchen
bei der schenkung nach da haben wir
jetzt darum haben wir jetzt quasi
planungs beschleunigungen 8 um diese
übertragung stunts selbst bauen so kann
man sonst können wir die kapazitäten die
im norden produziert werden sich ab
transit schweigen darf man bei der
windenergie ja keine
technikfolgenabschätzung gemacht hat das
ist ja schon seit jahrzehnten eigentlich
das große schlagwort
technikfolgenabschätzung ja wir wissen
doch das kann der landwirt
wahrscheinlich besser sagen dass diese
windkraftanlagen auch die böden
austrocknen wir wissen dass wir riesige
probleme haben die die materialien
irgendwann zu entsorgen wir wissen dass
milliarden von insekten auf die art und
weise und greifen hopps gehen ja
insekten wird man vielleicht seltener
gestochen auch wird das ist natürlich
auch wieder die futterquelle für vögel
usw usw mehr da leisten wir eine weiter
gegen die diversität der natur aber
entschuldige ist immer der
landwirtschaft hin zum sekten geht also
windenergieanlagen werden sie nicht mehr
gibt es eine interessante studie darüber
aber die wird niemals veröffentlicht
schuld an entdeckten sterben
grundsätzlich die landwirtschaft kein
anderer